hi there steve kaufman here um the
linguist on language blog
today i'm going to talk about reading
so it's not directly related to language
learning but it is in a way because
reading is one of the best ways to learn
languages including your own
and i posted on my blog
that i in fact i quoted an article in
the new york times
where they had described a teacher in
new york who was or somewhere in the
states
who had decided to let her
students pupils
decide what they wanted to read rather
than giving them you know a list of
books that they had to read and i said
this was a great idea
and we've had a lively controversy on
the subject a number of people have come
to say
you know uh what school for if you can't
uh you know dictate to the kids what
they should read
uh we have to maintain a tradition of a
common
culture
so many of the classics are such
wonderful books and
and so forth and so on
and uh
you know
um i'm not sure what i'm going to say
here today i just want to get on the
ramble on the subject but you know most
of the good books that i have read most
of the interesting books
i have read i have read since i left
school in fact i can't really remember
what we did at school i know we did
shakespeare and we didn't understand
much of it i know that they did a lot of
poetry and the reason for that is that
it's easy to do poetry the teacher gets
up in the classroom she opens a page
there's a whole poem so you can do that
in the classroom we had some books to
read i can't remember i think we had to
do the 39 steps or something we had 1984
we had what else did we have like i
can't we did the odyssey and the iliad
at one point
i can't remember very much
but i know that i like to read and when
i was a kid i like to read
books on american history
i don't know why i mean i was canadian
but i loved all the books from the
frontier and canadian history were they
but they didn't have so many they had
whatever some guy in the mountain
mounted police who
did whatever he did but i loved reading
about american history i loved reading
about baseball i loved reading about
hockey
and as i got older i got interested in
different things and i think as i
reached high school if i remember
correctly because we had so many things
that we had to read i didn't read for
pleasure anymore when i was younger i
read more for pleasure and then since
leaving school i have done more reading
for pleasure
i don't understand the people who say we
must get the kids to read certain
classics what are they afraid of
that once the kids leave school if you
don't force them to read these books
when you have them captive
then then people will never read these
books
then maybe the books aren't that useful
or interesting if they aren't powerful
enough on their own
the reality is
the big problem we have is that 40 of
the population in north america doesn't
read very well at all
and and and the the
the people who read that they sort of
divide the readers up into five
categories top 20 percent second third
fourth and fifth
the top 20 readers in terms of the
reading skills they get all the best
jobs they earn more money they're more
successful
they're obviously they do more reading
so they're also learning more things all
the time
the lower 20 can't function very well at
all even the second 20 doesn't do very
well so surely the goal has to be to get
people to become good readers then they
can decide what they want to read with
that
now some people will say well some
people may just read comics or you know
porno or something well they will for a
while but eventually most people will
get interested in something else because
a friend
tells them about something because they
saw a movie or or something will happen
to get them interested
and and i think to some extent doing
these famous books
in school when the kids have no
life experience to judge these books by
spoils them because then we will never
go back and read those books again
because it's now been turned into a task
at school which we did not really
knowing why and we'll never read that
book for pleasure again
the other thing of course they say well
you know because we have to assign tasks
to the readers and we have to you know
quiz them on their understanding and i
say don't quiz them understand
understanding just let them read it now
so what does the classroom do well the
classroom should be an opportunity for
people to express themselves if they're
not reading they may have to read in
class
again a book of their choice you could
limit it you could say here's
a hundred books choose something from
this list or if you want to read
something else come and tell us what it
is you would like to read so that you
can exercise some degree of control
how do you know they've read the book
well very simple they have to write
about what they read
we can devise questions where they have
to explain
maybe something related to the book or
what they liked about the book something
that would an opportunity for them to
demonstrate that they read the book
and i think we should also have them
explain the book in class now if
everybody read a different book that
could be quite interesting for everyone
to get up and give a brief summary
synopsis and critique of a book that
they read rather than everyone having to
read the same book
and you know
one of the people on my blog was saying
you know if people would read these
wonderful books you know if they've read
the diary of anne frank they'll never be
an anti-semite i don't believe that
not for a minute
um you know the 20th century
was the bloodiest
century in europe
uh maybe on a percentage basis the 30
years war was worse i don't know
but many of the people who committed
millions of people to slaughter in the
first world war who couldn't figure out
how to avoid senseless slaughter they
all read the classics of the time
i am sure that the people who were
behind
the fascists in italy and the nazis in
germany and all of their followers and
the in the russia and so forth i mean
stalin was a great poet
he loved poetry he read they're all red
they all read the classics
reading the classics doesn't make you a
better person
i'm not sure the reading makes you a
better person but
but there is no moral
requirement in my mind for people to
read this or that book and it carries on
beyond just literature
carries on into history and now i mean
we know that in different countries
you know historians
they want to constantly rewrite history
like this what's happening in russia
right now
they want to say that stalin was really
quite a good guy the fact that he
you know massacred
millions of peasants and killed his
people he didn't like or for whatever
frivolous reason and
deported whole nations half of whom died
on the way i mean that guy's a terrible
guy
but he it was very wise in terms of his
strategy
uh you know in signing the agreement
with uh with nancy germany where they
were their main suppliers of product
whenever it's over so they're rewriting
it all well
and and i'm sure that our histories are
biased i mean if you if you uh
you know read the history books in in in
canada and the us you think the whole
war was fought on the western front
uh not that there's uh you know we are
aware that that there was this other
stuff happening where in fact most of
the people were fighting but it's not
stressed so
you know rather than of course in japan
there are some very active rewriters of
history and there are in china
and uh you know here in canada as well i
mean there's people have agendas
and so the important thing is
to encourage kids
students to look at a variety of
different sources and then to come to
class and talk about what they've read
and let them have a discussion with
something somebody who read something
else you shouldn't have one history book
this is the history book and so it goes
through
throughout the humanities the emphasis
should be on encouraging people to
explore
and and the main objective in the in the
school system is for people to develop
this basic skills if forty percent of
the people are functionally illiterate
that's a bigger problem than
whether
many of them read to kill a mockingbird
or whatever it was that was considered a
classic doesn't matter if they're a good
reader they'll read lots of good stuff
but make sure they become a good reader
and the best way to make them a good
reader is to let them choose things that
are of interest to them and and i should
add like i'm always suspicious of all
these intellectuals and i mean yeah
whatever george russo doesn't matter
this fellow in russia who's got this
theory that the united states can have a
civil war within the next few months
he's a scientist he calls himself a
scientist of history what's a scientist
of history he's got his axe to grind
somebody else grinds in other acts the
best thing we can do is to let people
search for information and form their
own ideas and to be able to do that
they've got to be able to read so let's
make sure that they can all read
thank you